we need to be wary of the speed with
which a democratic country can drift
very quickly if we don't guard democracy
[Music]
is parliamentary politics in this
country broken does anyone think it is
by the way
oh yeah quite a lot of you were you the
people who took part in the UCL survey
they did a massive piece of polling uh
the Constitution unit there which found
that most people think democracy is not
always broken but certainly harmed not
working well and wanted and had lots of
great suggestions for improvements which
is great because so do I and so do many
think tanks and a year ago I was
speaking about truth and lies in
politics now I think it's quite
interesting to note that we're right in
the middle of the Parliamentary
privileges committees process there was
a lot of alliteration in that sentence
for which I don't apologize
um but we're in that process because
somebody is alleged to have misled
Parliament and I think it's really
important that we notice that a process
has kicked in there is a process going
on the Privileges committee I may fairly
say have kept stum which is quite right
they've virtually gone into conclave
every time I walked past Harriet Harman
who's the chair I kind of look at her
eyebrows to see if they know they're
getting up are they going down what's
happening nothing eyebrows absolutely
stationary
um but because
the New Evidence came out this week I'm
sorry I found it hard not to laugh about
this because we're paying for his brief
we're paying for his lawyers but because
we're paying for them they felt obliged
to disclose new evidence which they
found of his possible law breaking
alleged law breaking which is the right
and proper thing to do so it's one of
parliament's rich ironies I have
complained so many times in my shadow
leader of the House role about why are
we paying for this at legal advice well
it's because we're paying that there is
now more evidence about the parties in
checkers or alleged parties in checkers
now high profile scandals like these in
my view are a plague on certainly both
our houses in Parliament but all our
houses politically because people don't
in my view just think oh that's just
that MP they tend to then think that's
the whole lot of them
as with the expensive scandals so too
with the sexual harassment Scandal which
we're also in the middle of and people
in my view and understandably tend to
blame us as a body politic rather than
saying well it was just that person or
just that party and that's a problem
because when people lose faith in
democracy they lose faith in voting they
lose faith in challenging they lose
faith in holding us to account that
weakens the voter base it weakens
accountability and we lead gradually
then down a path that we really do not
want to go down and if you want to know
more about that I can highly recommend
Gideon rackman Financial Times
journalist his book on various autocrats
many of whom by the way got elected
democratically
and then pull the Democratic ladder up
behind them or try to so you know we
don't have to look too far there's an
election today
um so we we need to be wary of the speed
with which a democratic country can
drift very quickly if we don't guard
democracy even if we want to argue about
it even if we want to say look it's
broken but it's mendable
now as we get closer to a general
election you will see some of my
colleagues setting out their detailed
policy briefs and you're probably not
going to see mine because reforming
statutory instrument procedures is not a
sexy thing to put in a Manifesto though
to those of us that do it it really
matters I really think that we need to
take a cold hard look at how we
legislate that includes how we regulate
and there's lots of ways we could do it
better various think tanks who are as
nerdy no they are way nerdier than me
have come up with some really good
technical reasons so I just pay a bit
tribute here okay partly in case any of
them are here but also because they do
amazing work if you want the detail of
what I'm giving you politician Top Line
to Institute for government Constitution
unit fabulous Meg Russell
um and the Hansel Society they do really
great work I do not agree with them on
everything far from it in fact sometimes
I look at them and I think you're
writing what an academic would write
without thinking about politics and
politics does matter but they come up
with some really great things many of
which I'm going to be at least putting
to my colleagues in the shadow cabinet
as things I think we should do
now bear in mind that we have had I've
shadowed now three sword potential sword
carriers only one of them actually got
to do it and I bet Jacob Reese Morgan
was feeling pretty sick when he realized
that he missed out he was my first
he was my first but let's go back in
time if you were here last year sorry
I'm just going to mention it again Owen
Patterson anyone remember that scandal
it's important that we hang on to that
memory because that needs dealing with
and it's left a legacy with voters which
in my view has damaged us that if you
are an MP who has been found fairly and
squarely with evidence thoroughly sifted
according to the rules at the time to
have broken those rules and taken what
looks to me at least like a large amount
of money for a large amount of
ministerial access if you are found to
have done that and the government's
response as was Jacobs is to stand up
and say Here's a motion saying that he
should be expelled but I don't agree
with it and I'll now tell you about why
I don't agree with the motion that I'm
supposed to have proposed which was an
extraordinary moment I was opposite him
thinking I don't even know how I'm going
to respond to this because you've
literally just undermined your own
motion which should have been
straightforward up and down he's banter
rights according to the standards and
privileges committee according to the
standards commissioner who is an
independent person with great skill and
you're now saying you want to change the
rules retrospectively now that has
damaged us to damage the body politic it
has damaged people's views of
politicians which is they can just get
away with what they want because if they
don't like the rules they'll just make
another set I don't think that's true of
most MPS by the way and I certainly
witness many Tory MPS on that day in
that vote deeply unhappy
some of them voted with us others
abstained others did vote with the
government with gritted teeth
others with joy in their hearts I've got
to say but I think that is something we
need to notice and I want due respect
for conservative MPS who were not at all
happy
but whether it's the Patterson Scandal
or it's the unlawful closing of
parliament or Boris Johnson I mean when
we get to the end of the Privileges
committee we will know whether he was
knowingly misleading Parliament I was in
pmqs those three times when he said
three different things to roughly the
same question so be interesting to see
how they work through that or those
current sorry those formatory ministers
who we all saw if you follow there by
donkeys uh were accused of lining
plotting to line their own Pockets by up
to ten thousand pounds a day for a fake
Korean company now that matters to me
because I think we should have no paid
lobbying I just think MPS are MPS we
should not be paid lobbyists
shouldn't
we should not be paid lobbyists when I
knock on doors in Bristol where soon to
be called Bristol Central I don't want
people saying to me well who do you work
for do you work for me or do you work
for that fella that you're taking ten
thousand pounds a day from it's really
important that we're clean about that
and as I said the Constitution unit has
recently surveyed this and probably
surveyed some of you found 52 percent of
people either distrusted or strongly
distrusted Parliament which makes me
gulp for breath a bit I do think that's
a problem
because you get to vote for us and you
get to vote us out
and that but that survey has really
obsessed me and informed my thinking
um the public also said in that survey
that they wanted stronger mechanisms to
uphold Integrity including a more
powerful independent regulator and I
agree we've just seen in the last week
that there's a problem when it's up to
the prime minister to decide whether or
not one of his ministers is referred to
his ethics advisor and then takes a few
days over it and then decides not to now
I think that's a problem and we would
like to see in the labor party we'd like
to see that person or body everything we
actually want to replace quite a few of
these with one single independent ethics
and integrity commission that they
should be able to initiate yes thank you
I think so too they should be able to
initiate an inquiry not have to wait
until the prime time I think it's
actually damaged Boris Johnson to be
honest his own reputation because it
rested on him to decide whether or not
he referred himself and that is also
probable that was problematic wasn't it
should have been an independent process
um we had the illegal closing down of
parliament uh We've also had things that
are really tacky but I'm going to
mention them anyway because they're my
own hobby horses so um we have had
ministers who very publicly have not
turned up to select committee hearings
now select committees are not like all
party parliamentary groups that's all
party groups are where we pick an issue
and we do some work on it they've got to
be cross-party but they have no force a
select committee is a committee
cross-party by Statute it has the power
to compel Witnesses including ministers
so when ministers fail to turn up to be
scrutinized by the select committee
whose literal job it is is to scrutinize
them that is a problem and to turn up
after three or four times are being
asked is not in my view okay when urgent
questions are granted the right Minister
needs to turn up as legislation rolls
through Parliament we don't just need
the explanatory notes which actually to
be fair to the government do appear we
need the impact Assessments in good time
and if we don't have them our debate
about them is that necessarily poorer so
for me for me that means that I look at
that current setup where ministers are
also failing to answer parliamentary
questions in time again not all there
are some notable exceptions but it's not
okay that Penny repeatedly says yes I
will take that up for The Honorable
gentleman and I will make sure he or she
has a response months whichever side
it's on and I've got to say I'd be
really cross-party about this there are
Tori MPS as well as labor MPS and MPS
from other parties really unhappy with
certain government departments that do
not answer our questions and why does
that matter to you because they're your
questions they're the questions we ask
on your behalf they're the questions we
ask because you've told us that
something matters if we don't get
answers it's not just a boring
parliamentary techie thing it's a
problem for you for democracy for
politics we've then got a hefty pile of
bills getting stuck in the Lords
um and the the my colleagues in the
Lords are you know they're working flat
out they're sitting to Way Beyond
midnight I can tell you right now we're
not and and that's a problem as well
because it means that somewhere along
the line we're leaving the detail to our
colleagues in the Lords that's a very
bad sign indeed we're the elected
representatives
some of you may be people who say well
we should have a fully elected second
chamber I think we could argue that one
out and certainly the Gordon Brown
commission which Kirsten commissioned
for us on behalf of the day party is is
suggesting that we do do that opinions
vary on how effective that would be and
how you'd sort out Primacy but I
certainly know that while we've got a
House of Commons that's the
democratically elected body politic
where your representatives sit we should
be doing more scrutiny not less
we shouldn't be leaving it all up to the
Lords there should not be new amendments
appearing to bills in the Lords which my
colleague in this room I won't point to
to make her feel self-conscious but
she's nodding at me so I know I'm right
and it's not okay this is not okay
right so I've already mentioned we want
an independent ethics and integrity
commission there's an alphabet soup at
the moment around between the various
different bodies to scrutinize us as MPS
us as ministers and public figures in
general and I think the public needs to
be able to see
really concretely that it is done
independently that they the
Commissioners or commissioner in the
case of the standards commissioner can
initiate inquiries can take things up
and that would matter because I think
then you wouldn't get hopefully in time
that feeling of Despair that I hear from
so many constituents and certainly the
Constitution units work uh Bears this
out that feeling of Despair that nothing
happens nothing changes
we have a problem with sexual harassment
at the moment and this is one of those
things that a shadow leader of the house
I get to influence now I'm unlike my
colleagues I don't have to wait quite so
long to actually make some concrete
change but we're going to have a big
argument about it when it comes to the
commons on the 12th of June because not
everyone's going to like what we've come
up with uh penny and I have worked on
this I'm yet to discover whether she
loves it what we're doing or not but she
will propose the motion I will
effectively second it because it's a
piece of work done cross-party by the
House of Commons commission it may
surprise some of you to know that we
don't have a mechanism for removing
someone temporarily from the House of
Commons if they are accused of serious
sexual violence rape or or assault now
that happens in every other big
organization
you would get gardening leave or
something based on risk and that's
important it wouldn't be for everything
we are calling this a risk-based
exclusion policy and it's a temporary
policy it's temporary procedure but it
is a big deal to get MPS to vote to
delegate responsibility to another body
that isn't all MPS
to decide who can sit in our house
effectively to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit iai.tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas